cuando observamos dentro de las células
eucariotas vemos organelos unidos a la
membrana y algunos de estos organelos
que están unidos a la membrana son
particularmente interesantes por ejemplo
aquí tenemos el diagrama de un
cloroplasto que encontramos en células
de plantas o algas y sabemos que aquí es
donde se realiza la fotosíntesis pero lo
que es realmente interesante es que
parece que los cloroplastos contienen la
maquinaria necesaria para hacer una
célula procariotas no la vemos actuando
por sí misma pero tiene su propio adn
tiene ribosomas que sabemos que es el
sitio donde pasa el arn mensajero a
proteína y de la misma manera otro
organelos unido a la membrana que
encontramos en las células eucariotas y
esto incluye a las células animales y
las células en nuestros cuerpos que son
las mitocondrias las mitocondrias a
menudo son vistas como las fábricas de
energía de las células eucariotas donde
podemos aprovechar el oxígeno para
producir atp y de la misma manera que
los cloroplastos
las mitocondrias tienen su propio adn
también tienen ribosomas mitocondriales
aquí tenemos algunos diagramas de cómo
se ve la mitocondria dentro de una
célula más grande por muchas décadas los
biólogos evolucionistas analizaron esto
y dijeron por qué existen estas cosas
porque se ven casi como células
procariotas incluso hay ejemplos de
células procariotas bacterias
procariotas independientes que viven en
simbiosis dentro de otras células y se
ven tan mal como las mitocondrias y los
cloroplastos y así si nos remontamos a
la década de los años 60 una persona
llamada lynn margulis apareció en escena
con la teoría endo simbiótica y su
opinión es que estos órganos de los
unidos a la membrana como las
mitocondrias y los cloroplastos bueno si
profundizamos en nuestro pasado
evolutivo digamos hace 2500 millones de
años sus ancestros eran en realidad
organismos procariotas independientes
que podían producir energía aeróbica
mente o usar oxígeno
fueron precursores de lo que hoy
consideramos como células eucariotas
modernas que ya podrían tener algunas
estructuras unidas a la membrana como un
núcleo y tal vez algunas otras cosas que
solo podían metabolizar las cosas
anaeróbica mente no podían aprovechar el
oxígeno mientras que estos otros
personajes podían aprovechar el oxígeno
y luego podrían haberse convertido en
simbiontes donde el que podía aprovechar
el oxígeno para producir más energía
sería engullido por la célula más grande
y esa célula más grande era capaz de
proporcionar nutrientes y protección
mientras que la célula más pequeña que
estaba envuelta en su interior era capaz
de metabolizar mejor los nutrientes y
aprovechar el oxígeno para producir más
energía y con el tiempo esta relación
simbiótica se conectó aún más de modo
que el organismo más pequeño que no
podía funcionar por sí mismo perdió
parte de su adn que era necesario para
actuar de forma independiente y parte de
él podría haberse incorporado al adn de
la célula más grande
y esos organismos más pequeños son los
que finalmente evolucionaron en lo que
hoy consideramos que son las
mitocondrias esta es una teoría
fascinante y en realidad se ha
demostrado cuando lynn margulis publicó
por primera vez esto a fines de la
década de los años 60
ella no fue tomada tan en serio pero en
las décadas posteriores esto ha sido
validado mientras observamos las
estructuras de adn de las mitocondrias y
los cloroplastos de hecho esta es la
teoría más probable de cómo surgieron en
nuestras células y es una visión
fascinante de la evolución en general
anteriormente hablamos mucho sobre la
selección natural y el papel de la
variación y las mutaciones pero lynn
margulis introduce otra idea que podría
catalizar la evolución y es la de la
simbiosis porque encontramos la
simbiosis en todo el mundo natural y su
argumento es que a veces esos implantes
pueden volverse tan codependientes entre
sí que se funden en un solo organismo
hasta el próximo vídeo